[Music]
last week astronomers discovered a
massive planet 10 times bigger than
jupiter orbiting a part of extremely hot
stars
me and jesse
it's six to ten times heavier than our
sun the record-breaking alien planet is
called b centauri b
and it's challenging what we know about
space because scientists previously
thought it'd be too hot for a planet to
form in so will this change everything
we know about the galaxy and the life
forms that reside in it there's only one
life form i could think of to help us
make sense of all of this a mighty space
beast who also happens to have the voice
of an angel he's also part of the
greatest band that ever was or will ever
be gwar joining us for the first time in
studio gwar lee vocalist blothar
the berserker
that's right
well first off with all these coven
restrictions is it hard to travel
well i mean of course it's hard to
travel it's hard for me to get through a
doorway
i feel you
[Laughter]
yeah you're you're the only guest that's
larger than tyrus
well
i don't know about that
i don't feel larger than tyrus i'm
amazed
that is a big dude right there
it's all me
i just want to stare at both of you so
tell me what do you make of this giant
planet oh giant man well i mean you know
if you want to know about things that
are hot and fat obviously you're going
to ask me
[Laughter]
you know i think that it just
underscores the insignificance of
humanity if you want to know what what
what true insignificance is just look in
the mirror greg that's that's that's
what you're gonna see i like this guy
do you think you could sit in for me on
the five uh well
i know dana's a stickler
it's not me that would have a problem
with it what do you think of uh elon
musk he has this idea he wants to create
like a noah's ark spaceship that would
be packed full of animals to go to mars
is this a good or bad idea i mean i
think it's a great idea especially if he
just flies it directly into the sun yes
that's what i'd like to see
fried zebra
yes
yeah you're quarters not a fan of
animals no i mean we love animals we
just you know maybe not elon musk but
you know i mean it's just just the idea
of of a of a noah's ark sailing directly
into the sun is extremely appealing to
me it's it is it is
you do you do you do enjoy the
destruction of all earthlings we often
forget that those are earthlings too
that's right yeah yes animals are
athletes too although they generally get
a pass because yes that's right but but
the downside of uh those earthlings they
don't create crack
no they don't create crack but they do
create crap and we appreciate that yes
yes well you're right what do you do
with crap
what are you about we smoke it just like
everything else
hey have you been following this thing
going on in colorado blowthar something
about like they're hearing these
mysterious sounds from under a lake in
colorado springs
you know what i wish people would just
leave me alone while i'm trying to have
a bm you know
people always with a glass at the door
trying to listen
it's so hard to be a celebrity it is it
is not a single moment of privacy do you
get uh when you're on earth uh do you
get recognized a lot from
earthlings or do they
they generally turn and run in terror
yes yes they certainly recognize that
their doom is imminent when they see me
yeah or are you often mistaken for alec
baldwin
no nobody mistakes me for that not alec
baldwin dom deluise i get like
love by the way so uh what when uh do
you have any masks where do you get your
masks
your coven masks how do they fit on your
face i never wear a mask as you can see
yes
i am absolutely maskless no i mean i
mean i can't nothing fits me i don't buy
off the rag greg like you yes
i buy off a very tiny rack at gaps kids
no i don't i i can't find a mask that
fits me let's just put it like that yeah
but i do think humans should wear masks
i mean you should wear them all the time
if if you're wearing you to wear them
and rob a bank yes then why don't you
just wear them every day so you always
look like you're robbing a bank plus
humans are ugly really young that's true
you know it's true you have probably a
different uh a different uh concept of
beauty on your planet from a scale of
one to ten what are you
on on on your planet well i mean i've
i'm unrateable obviously yes
i'm a 10 and a half i'm an 11. i'm off
the charts yes yes but i mean you know
my my fairness
is is is unmatched yes in the universe
obviously but somebody like you i mean i
would say you know
six and a half oh why thank you yeah
i'll take that a six and a half i got uh
last question for you uh christmas eve
we always see norad tracking santa as he
flies around the globe
uh do you enjoy that what would you do i
mean obviously we would try to shoot him
down but
i mean if you've already gotten the
military involved just scramble those
jets and bring that fat s.o.b to the
ground
blows better knows how to party man yeah
he does he does
yes all right blothar always a pleasure
to have you here well it's a pleasure to
be here yeah how long was that geez yes
that was a good six minutes six minutes
all right all right that's how we
usually do it here i think he wants to
hang out here all day yeah maybe she did
the whole show once in a while yeah what
the hell you know i'll do it you got to
read up on the topics though
i don't read
[Laughter]
neither is water
yeah get in his waters
all right thank you blothar that's gwar
by the records
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else